notre correspondant à bruxelles jean
jacques guéry bonjour jean jacques le
président ukrainien dont qui demande à
l'union européenne des gestes concrets
oui absolument et le président ukrainien
volodimir et les x qui a parlé pendant
10 minutes face aux députés réunis dans
l'hémicycle pour cette session
extraordinaire du parlement consacrée
donc à la guerre en ukraine il était
seul sur un fond blanc assis dans un
fauteuil derrière une table et le chef
de l'état ukrainien il a livré un
discours à la fois très émouvant mais
aussi extrêmement combatif je crois que
c'est ça qu'il faut retenir
personne ne nous briseront nous sommes
forts at il dit aux députés chaque jour
n'est pas un bon jour et chaque soir et
peut-être le dernier avant de lancer
véritablement un appel à l'aide au
soutien de l'union européenne à la fin
de son allocution sans vous d'ukraine
restera seul prouvez nous que vous êtes
européen prouvez nous que vous allez
nous soutenir ne nous lâchait pas ce
discours là il a été unanimement
applaudie par des députés européens de
boue certains d'entre eux s'étaient même
enveloppés dans des drapeaux ils
craignent un et nombreux étaient ceux
qui portaient des signes de soutien à
kiev et c'est sous les applaudissements
que luan que l'on a alors vu le
président ukrainien serrer le poing
avant de sortir du champ à la fin de son
allocution dès l'ouverture de cette
session extraordinaire d'ailleurs le
parlement avait voulu montrer un son
soutien l'ukraine le parlement européen
est votre allié avait lancé roberta mais
de cela la présidente du parlement les
agresseurs ne sont pas les bienvenus
l'europe est prête à aller plus loin
encore en toile de fond il y avait bien
sûr la demande de kiev d'adhérer à
l'union signée hier par volodymyr
zemlinsky réponse de robert thomas de
ceux-là nous reconnaissons la
perspective de l'adhésion craignait nous
travaillons ce sens nous devons et nous
voulons affronter l'avenir ensemble
mais ce message ne veut pas dire
adhésion immédiate comme l'avait demandé
hier le président ukrainien si les
européens doit bien voter tout à l'heure
une résolution soutenant la perspective
d'une adhésion de qui lève à l'union un
texte soutenu par les principaux groupes
politiques
ce texte s'il est sans force
contraignante ça veut dire que ce serait
un message politique message politique
très fort sans doute mais ce ne sera pas
plus que ça selon les procédures
européennes en vigueur une éventuelle
décision des yeux relève en effet des 27
états membres à l'unanimité et tout ça
arrive après l'examen d'un très grand
nombre de critères qui doivent
correspondre aux standards et aux
valeurs de l'union autrement dit ça
prend plusieurs années merci beaucoup
jean jacques et